welcome back to h20 special relativity
in this short video we want to see how
special relativity
here short and sr
fits into the general landscape of
physics series very likely you have
listened to
801 last semester
or at some previous time in your career
at mit
and
once we enter the discussion of special
relativity it might seem to you that
what you learned there is was simply
incorrect
a better way to look at this is that you
know each of those physics theories
they have a range of validity a range in
which the theory
theory works and describes physical
phenomena
and so here in this picture i'd like to
point out that
even special relativity has its own
range of mobility
but let's start with classical mechanics
so classical mechanics describes
the motion of objects collision of
objects the rotation of objects in 802
you are studying electrodynamics
but you do that typically at mit in
those courses at velocities which are
modest small velocities small velocities
compared to the speed of light once you
accelerate once you
have velocities which are really really
large
then
the description breaks the validity of
those series breaks and that's where
special velocity comes in
and it's especially important when you
discuss um
very fast moving bodies more fast-moving
reference frames or behavior of light
and so this is what special relativity
does the range of validity is
basically you know fast moving phenomena
is high speed
but special relativity by itself doesn't
help you to understand for example
object of small scales in order to have
a proper description here you need to
study quantum mechanics
if you have objects of very much large
or with large accelerations
uh you need to enter
a generalized view general relativity
and if you for example combine high
velocities in small scales you have to
study quantum field series
so the point of this slide is really to
point out that special relativity has a
specific use case it's limited
um it describes fast moving objects it
doesn't describe large accelerations for
example so that that is the
generalization you get when you study
general relativity
so in summary special relativity is
a complete description of physical
phenomena at high speed
it is consistent with 801 and 802 and we
will later see that whenever we find
integration of motion on
at for objects at high speed we can
if we
use smaller velocities we will find the
solutions of 801 and 803
when we combine
special relativity with quantum
mechanics it describes quantum fields
theories and as i was saying the
generalization of special relativity as
r is general relativity gr